hi good morning I don't know
I want to talk about how to use the time
that stubborn stubborn now what to do
listen it is a
lot why because it is to preserve a child
no children learn their language they
already know because it is portuguese because the
brain learned I learned a lot
experience have have experience with
have not in the language will be able to do one
we have to do the same thing is but
we have to develop a
content strategy listen to it for
me it is very important i want a
balance between simple things that
we can listen to the na  again many
times the same thing to create habits
in the brain and things more difficult
team more difficult more interesting
more difficult forever we are
listening to the same thing
and the brain learns - yes - because the
brain needs repetition
because it also needs novelty  so you
have to make a balance to
practice to believe new habits in the
language we have to listen to
the brain many times as well  it's more difficult
netflix things we can import
olympus for example is we don't even have my
story my story so it's I
use the ministers always eat as
physical exercise and how to do
exercises for the oven stomach
of pará to be stronger for the
door to be able to believe in your
abilities in the language we also have to
look for new things like vocabulary
soon to believe in the language so
things and if you don't understand everything it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter is to give the
brain this opportunity to
experience how the language and tone become  you
have this is the experience with the language
in the grammar explanations
the train felt and you do not have this
experience with the language through you will
listen to listen to it in the
grammar explanations you will not understand it is not worth
remembering it is worth nothing so one this
period is
the  canada in brasilia any country we
can't there
we can practice the language there you
understand but language stays through
listening and reading  reading reading we can
do it is simply not to say
things to do work breakfast
an ability now I'm going
is a sandal to import content
to Linda I believe it can be very
very useful and
oh well see you later
and then
and there
and  there
andthere
and there
[Music]
andthere
and there
[Music]
andthere
g1
and there
andthere
and  there